[Applause]
it is hard to believe it's been 20 years
since that Backstreet Boys classic and
yes we know back streets back but
clearly they never left and only I was
with them in Las Vegas as they dropped
one major BSB exclusive that's your boy
is it but we've been around forever
yeah we're just getting started ladies
that's crazy the world tours in May of
next year the tenth album comes out
January 25th
[Music]
we took our time in making this record
that we wanted it to be the best that it
could be hopefully you know 12 singles
strong would be nice so a world tour and
brand-new music I mean quit playing
games with my heart
[Music]
chances the latest single off
backstreets new album called DNA dropped
today and we have the exclusive
behind-the-scenes look at the making of
the music video the song itself is just
it's super deep but it's Backstreet Boys
being Backstreet Boys by oh what a
chance that we'd be here after 25 years
[Music]
this big world tour you are in great
shape because you've been doing this
residency for a year do we even have to
train we're always like kind of training
in but once we go home for the holidays
we're going to holiday food and we're
gonna be with our kids and you can do
pretend if you pretend that you're like
22 or 25 your body you can try to trick
yourself you know it just hurts when you
get up the next day and I did not know
this as a lifelong fan but people
confuse you with Justin Timberlake yeah
sometimes I got it from like three guys
they're like oh there's Justin
Timberlake I'm like don't get your
groups right you don't even have like a
frosted tip a curly noodle hair Justin
Timberlake is here but he's no Bryan I
love you guys and I can't wait for this
to our tickets go on sale November 14th
it's gonna be the groups of biggest
arena tour in 18 years it kicks off mate
11th in Portugal through Europe and then
back to the US on July 11th
[Applause]